[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal de tv 78 c'est l'édition de la
rédaction pour revenir sur l'actualité
locale et régionale tout de suite les
titres de ce mardi 2 juillet la visite
de la ministre de la justice dans les
yvelines nicole belloubet était ce matin
à la maison d'arrêt de bois d'arcy sur
place la garde des sceaux a présenté la
nouvelle feuille de route du
gouvernement sur la santé des détenus
le département touché par les noyades
notamment chez les plus jeunes une
personne de 21 ans décédé ce week-end à
achères et un enfant sauvé de peu à
versailles l'enseignement de la natation
est il suffisant quels sont les conseils
pour éviter les incidents nous en
parlons avec notre invité
enfin les gendarmes des yvelines ont un
nouveau patron le colonel sylvain
tortelier va prendre ses fonctions le
1er août
il remplace le colonel loïc barras la
passation de commandement se déroulait
hier à la préfecture des yvelines
et puis c'est tout à l'heure dans ce
journal le projet solidaire de deux
policières pour l'association des
orphelins de la police nationale les
suites dé la suite des violents
affrontements de la nuit de samedi à
dimanche à saint germain en laye deux
hommes ont été présentés à un juge au
tribunal de versailles ce lundi ils sont
originaires de saint germain et de
chanteloup les vignes
une trentaine de personnes étant tous
concernés par cette bagarre entre bandes
rivales qui a fait sept blessés dont
trois graves
ces derniers sont finalement tiré
d'affaires la préfecture des yvelines a
ordonné le déploiement de forces de
sécurisation sur place elles resteront
jusqu'à ce que le calme soit totalement
revenue la garde des sceaux nicole
belloubet en visite ce matin à la maison
d'arrêt de bois d'arcy accompagné de la
secrétaire d'état christelle du boss
ella a dévoilé les grandes lignes de sa
feuille de route relative feuille de
route pour améliorer l la santé des
détenus aurélie ronces pour le sujet ce
document contient les 28 mesures mises
en place par le gouvernement pour
améliorer la santé des détenus dans
cette maison d'arrêt de bois d'arcy les
personnes incarcérées ont accès à une
unité hospitalière ou encore un centre
de lutte contre les addictions
on rencontre beaucoup de gens pour qui
il n'y a pas de ya pas beaucoup de
contacts avec le monde de la santé à
l'extérieur on a une population assez
jeunes sur bois d'arcy également et puis
on a des patients qui sont qui sont très
vulnérables qui ont sont dans des
situations sociales compliqué à
l'extérieur et qui ont mauvais accès aux
soins scie à bois d'arcy les structures
médicales sont adaptés pour prendre en
charge les détenus ce n'est pas le cas
partout
d'où cette feuille de route qui s'étend
jusqu'en 2022 et qui a plusieurs
objectifs
c'est permettre d'avoir un bilan je
pense notamment aux jeunes qui sont sous
protection judiciaire lié à la jeunesse
avec une facilité un bilan de santé
dès qu'ils sont en détention c'est aussi
de la prévention par rapport au suicide
la formation auprès des professionnels
pénitentiaire mais aussi professionnels
de santé prévenir aussi en termes de
dépendance est elle liée au handicap
favorisons la détection des personnes
détenues qui ont ces difficultés là
autre mesure annoncée le développement
de la télémédecine ou encore la mise en
place de stages en milieu pénitentiaire
pour les internes en médecine la
réinsertion des détenus est également
concernée c'est aussi notre volonté de
travailler sur la continuité du parcours
de soins après la sortie de la détention
c'est un défi majeur tout notre enjeu
c'est de faire le lien entre ce qui se
passe dans la détention et en dehors de
la détention
je crois que c'est un enjeu capital pour
éviter la récidive
il est également prévu d étude nationale
sur la santé mentale des personnes
détenues le dernier état des lieux date
d'il ya 15 ans en marge de cette visite
nicole belloubet s'est également exprimé
sur un autre sujet le résultat de la
consultation citoyenne menée il ya
quelques semaines à la maison centrale
de poissy les pisciacais ont voté non à
82% pour le maintien de la prison en
centre ville
écoutez la réponse de la ministre sur la
question qui a été posée par monsieur le
maire de poissy qui
souhaite un transfert de la prison qui
est actuellement centre ville sur un
autre terrain moi je lui et je lui ai
dit très clairement que je souhaitais
que la prison reste en centre ville que
si il me propose un terrain si les
financements et trouver au delà de ce
que l'état compte mettre pour réparer
l'actuelle prison
eh bien nous pourrions l'envisager mais
pour le moment je n'ai pas eu de retour
en ce sens de sa part dans le reste de
l'actualité en bref le coup dur pour les
salariés de conforama selon les
représentants des syndicats le groupe
sud-africain va annoncer un vaste plan
de restructuration en france 32 magasins
qui compte 1000 50 salariés vont fermer
en tout 1900 postes vont être supprimés
en ile de france
huit boutiques conforama est aussi
maison des pauses sont concernés on ne
sait pas pour le moment ainsi des
magasins ed et yves une figure dans
cette liste 600 suppressions d'emploi
seraient également prévues au siège
social du groupe et dans les
établissements restant ouverts les
résultats du bac 2010 9 seront dévoilés
ce vendredi mais il se pourrait que les
près de 71 mille candidats dans les
yvelines doivent patienter davantage
après la grève des surveillances de
surveillance de certaines épreuves
plusieurs correcteurs ont prévu de ne
pas envoyer les notes du baccalauréat
acte de protestation contre les réformes
du lycée et de l'examen ses professeurs
souhaitent la réouverture de
négociations avec l'éducation nationale
un mouvement qui concerne les yvelines
au lycée hoche de versailles les trois
jurys du bac es font grève aujourd'hui
ce qui pourrait perturber allaient
remonter de résultats eux se battent
pour le maintien de ce service au centre
ville de trappes une association aide
habitants soutenus par la cgt le parti
communiste local s'opposent à la
fermeture du bureau de poste rue pierre
semard
il doit s cessé son activité en 2020
dans le cadre de la réorganisation des
agences sur le territoire opéré par le
groupe
une action était organisée samedi devant
le site concerné et plusieurs pétitions
ont été lancées pour faire annuler la
décision est les propos recueillis sur
place par yves hugstein berger il ya
trois pétitions actuellement qu'ici
kuhn de trappes à gauche une de la cgt
une de l'association de défense des
services publics pour faire en sorte que
cette décision soit reconsidérée et elle
doit l'être notamment par le fait que tu
rappes a été reconnue dans le dispositif
coeur de ville et donc redynamisation
économique et social et dans ce cadre là
on pourrait pas comprendre qu'ils
viennent une suppression d'un service
public et de son côté le maire guy
malandain le maire divers gauche de
trappes affirmé sont en profond
désaccord avec la poste elle dans un
courrier adressé aux habitants il y fait
état notamment de l'ouverture d'un
relais poste dans un café un café un
futur café culturel qui sera mise en
place dans la ville
le premier ministre edouard philippe en
a fait état en fin de semaine dernière
les noyades sont en augmentation
sensible depuis le début de l'été en
témoignent deux derniers épisodes
survenus ce week-end dans les yvelines
un jeune de 21 ans s'est noyé lors d'une
baignade dans l'étang de bausch débauche
hr samedi samedi toujours dans un
camping à versailles c'est un enfant de
trois ans qui a été sauvé de peu d'une
noyade en piscine alors comment éviter
que de tels incidents se produisent on
en parle avec mon invité gilles ragon
soir bonsoir
vous êtes le président du comité des
yvelines de la fff 2 sc la fédération
française de sauvetage et de secourisme
on a vu il ya une période de canicule 1
qui s'est produite la semaine dernière
et ce week-end est ce que c'est une
période où les incidents se multiplient
ce qualité aussi fabrice ce genre
d'incident tellement les périodes de
canicule qu'on a vécu la semaine
dernière et les périodes estivales
forcément
ainsi un site un peu plus à la baignade
ce qui nous pose problème parce qu'ils
posent problème du maire général sur le
binage sauvage et bien qu'ils ne sont
pas surveillées à des heures où il ya
personne là dans le cadre de l'étang à
achères par exemple c'est en étant où la
baignade est interdite
effectivement on ne faut pas prendre de
risque en quand il ya des panneaux
d'interdiction exactement le reste bien
lorsque l'abbé nathalie que c'est jamais
pour rien qu'il avait pour le plaisir si
jamais pour le plaisir d'interdire sait
simplement qu'il ya des risques et que
ces risques ne sont pas maîtrisés quand
il ya personne sur place nous avons nous
trouvons des personnes qui arrivent à se
baigner après s'être fortement alcoolisé
alors prêts passés des longues périodes
de au soleil ça se dorer donc ça c'est
très bien en soi mais il ya des
conséquences derrière et aussi la
méconnaissance des lieux est également
le manque d'habitude de l'opra conclave
concrètement pour l'enfant de 3 ans dans
un camping il faut rappeler également
offert en vigilance des parents peut
être il avait échappé à la vigilance de
ses parents voilà je ne sais pas dans ce
cas là pour la si vous me dites
effectivement je la prends mais
effectivement il faut que les parents
soient conscients qu'un enfant même s'il
est à l'aise dans l'eau gérer même
surtout si à l'aise en lozère il faut le
surveiller encore plus que les autres et
dire que une bouée des brassards ne
suffisent pas c'est seulement une
précaution en plus mais ça n'empêche pas
la noyade la noyade dans une boue et des
brasseurs n'empêche pas dans des enfants
qui arrivent à se noyer tout en ayant
une bouille il suffit que les enfants
basculent n'arrive pas à se redresser
il reste la tête sous l'eau et peut se
noyer c'est une sécurité suivants d'air
quand on à l'enfant avec soin ainsi on
maîtrise pas bien lieu aquatique c'est
bien d'avoir une bouée mais c'est pas la
garantie à 100%
il faut absolument que les parents
prennent conscience qu'une bouée c'est
pas un sauf-conduit cunca maître nageur
il n'est pas là pour surveiller un
enfant mais ils surveillent des
centaines d'offres du bassin et le sens
d'assurer un ensemble et que fatalement
si le parent n'est pas responsable qui
prend la baignade comme un lieu
de loisirs sans danger c'est une erreur
c'est dans le cas des piscines publiques
de aussi de ballades enfin de sortie à
la plage pour les piscines privées parce
que ça arrive aussi qu'ils aient des
incidents dans des piscines privées
quelles sont les précautions à prendre
des précautions
déjà c'est pas laisser un enfant seul au
bord des piscines même privés et ceux
consacrés à la surveillance même des
enfants qui sont au beau fixe entre vais
essayer de mettre des barrières faire en
sorte que l'accès au bassin ne soit pas
ne soit pas facile c'est vrai que quand
vous laissez un bassin complètement
libre complètement nue et sans
surveillance
vous avez de fortes de fortes chances
par une chance contre guillemets fort du
risque d'avoir un enfant qui se
retrouvent à flotter au bout d'un an le
phénomène aussi des noyades sèche c'est
une personne qui meurt plusieurs heures
après avoir bu la tasse comment on peut
être vigilant sur la glace est un petit
peu plus compliqué puisque en fait il
serait il semblerait que ces noyades
sèche soit l'inhalation de dos dans le
niveau du pont mais que ça ne soit pas
suffisant pour recréer des créer une
noyade immédiate mais que ça se produise
a plu à plusieurs en plusieurs heures
voire plusieurs jours après la vigilance
lorsqu'on est à la piscine ou dans une
baignade quelle qu'elle soit que ce soit
la mer ou dans un étang si l'enfant tout
si l'enfant a des douleurs au niveau de
la poitrine ne pas penser à sous silence
le fait de tous et on sait tous que
lorsqu'on à voile un petit peu travers
ont tous mais ça ne dure pas quand la
tous installés qui a des douleurs au
niveau de la poitrine
il faut quand même consulté il faut pas
hésiter à aller aux urgences est
demandée expliquer la situation
pour autant quel concert de conseillers
d'acompte dans quelles circonstances
sont produits c'est ses ventes et le
tout sur les noyades est ce que le
problème aussi et pas autre part une
récente étude il rend qui montre qu'un
français sur sept ne sait pas nager si
une étude de santé publique france à une
récente étude
on sait que les noix et peuvent toucher
les adultes et les seniors notamment
mais elle concerne aussi et surtout les
jeunes et qui a pas un problème sur
l'enseignement de la natation en avance
un problème son enseignement je ne pense
pas puisque les enseignants qui viennent
dans les piscines et qui suivent des
cours avec les maîtres nageurs suivent
un programme le peut-être de soucis que
l'on rencontre c'est qu'on a familiarise
beaucoup les enfants à l'eau si on leur
apprend à ne pas avoir leur de l'eau
mais on oublie de leur apprendre à nager
derrière donc c'est à dire qu'on a des
enfants qui sont très avec très à l'aise
qu'ils sont qui aime et qui aime bien
l'eau qui aime bien elle au bord de
l'eau qui aime bien jouer dans l'eau
mais qui ne mettraient qui croient
maîtriser mais qui ne maîtrise pas donc
là c'est un petit sous là dessus
peut-être qu'il y aura des améliorations
améliorations à apporter
puisque les rennais statistique que vous
donnez on avait les mêmes quasiment dans
les années 60
donc ça veut dire que ça n'a pas évolué
et pourtant les habitudes de l'eau ont
considérablement évolué en terme de
bassin et en terme de fréquentation et
on précise juste un petit on arrive à la
fin de cet entretien que votre
fédération et bien sûr une mission de
sensibilisation mais aussi elle propose
de nombreuses formations toutes les
informations à soi à retrouver sur le
site internet qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran merci gilles rancune tenace et
au président du comité des yvelines de
la fédération française de sauvetage et
de secourisme la fff 2s merci d'être
passé en plateau merci le gouvernement a
annoncé sa feuille de route pour les
collectivités territoriales
un nouvel acte de la décentralisation
est prévue pour 2020 une réorganisation
aussi des services de l'état sur les
territoires est d'ores et déjà lancé des
réformes qui sont attendus par les élus
des yvelines le reportage de nicolas
d'ombré la mise en oeuvre de la réforme
de l'organisation territoriale de l'état
c'est l'objet de la circulaire du 12
juin envoyée par le premier ministre aux
préfets
elle rappelle notamment c'est à
l'échelon départemental que doivent être
mises en oeuvre les politiques de l'état
une directive rappelé par le préfet des
yvelines lors de son intervention devant
l'assemblée départementale le vendredi
28 juin et illustré avec l'exemple de la
loi sru sur le seuil de logements
sociaux imposé aux communes
notre interprétation sera toujours
positive partir du travail de terrain
mobilisons tous les moyens pour
accompagner dans ce cadre réglementaire
en effet contraignant et que notre
vision des choses sera toujours une
vision bienveillant pour une application
la plus intelligentes et imaginatives de
la loi du côté des institutions
décentralisées conseillers municipaux ou
départementaux maires ou présidents de
départements les attentes sur l'acte de
décentralisation sont importantes alors
je pense qu'il faut donner plus de
pouvoir aux collectivités tout ce que
l'état ne fait pas bien à l'échelon
central il faut le confier aux
collectivités l'état lui doit mieux
faire ce qui est le coeur de son métier
c'est la défense c'est la sécurité
c'est la diplomatie bien entendu et qui
sont aussi les hommes de l'unité
nationale mais localement on n'est plus
opérationnel nokia les communes et on
soutient de ces communes il y a les
départements les départements qui
coordonne qui accompagne les communes
leur intercommunalité je dirais de
redonner à la proximité et redonner aux
territoires les compétences et
l'autorité et la responsabilité qu'ils
doivent avoir
qui mieux que les élus de territoire je
dirais sur la proximité sont à même de
mettre en place une réorganisation sur
la réorganisation des services de l'état
dans le département les directives sont
en cours d'application
le gouvernement lancera en 2020 la
réforme sur les collectivités
territoriales
mais la gendarmerie nationale des
yvelines va avoir un nouveau commandant
à partir du 1er août le colonel sylvain
tortelier va prendre ses fonctions à la
place du colonel loïc barras la
passation de commandement entre les deux
officiers s'est tenue ce lundi 1er
juillet en préfecture des yvelines
nicolas landry était sur place
la gendarmerie nationale des yvelines a
rassemblé dans la cour de la préfecture
une cérémonie de passation de
commandement le groupement départemental
connaissons nouveau commandant le
colonel sylvain tortelier commandé dans
ce magnifique département des yvelines
avec autant de vies diversité autant de
problématiques
ça rend le challenge est des filles
d'autant plus intéressant c'est de voir
le contact avec la population les élus
et les grands représentants que nous
pouvons donc mieux finalement sentir le
pouls de ce département et donc a
fortiori répondre aux attentes de la
population aurait après des fonctions
opérationnelles à annecy à porto vecchio
il occupe aussi des postes
interministériel et au sein de l'état
major de la gendarmerie nationale il
vient remplacer le colonel loïc barras
commandant du groupement des yvelines
depuis trois ans ses qualités sont
d'abord l'inventivité la pertinence et l
extrême agilité intellectuelle qui l'a
mise en avant et sur laquelle il s'est
appuyé justement pour comprendre les
enjeux analyser mais les situations et
proposer toujours des solutions
intelligentes et pertinente et réaliste
le colonel loïc barras va de son côté
occupé des fonctions au sein de la
direction générale de la gendarmerie
nationale à issy les moulineaux et le
préfet des yvelines a profité de la
cérémonie pour récompenser elektra c'est
une staff y de 10 ans membre du groupe
d'investigation cynophile de la
gendarmerie
cette chaîne est spécialisée dans la
recherche de stupéfiants et de billets
de banque
la gendarme va prendre sa retraite cet
été après services rendus de la
gendarmerie à la police l'interview à
présent dans ce journal de deux
policières qui mène en ce moment un
projet solidaire les détails dans cet
entretien enregistré lundi
[Musique]
elle souhaite s'envoler pour le costa
rica deux policières dont l'une
travaillant dans les yvelines vont
participer au 5e raid de la saharienne
dans le péril qui est le pays d'amérique
centrale en décembre prochain pour en
parler elles sont en plateau charlotte
et marine bonsoir dit ça et vous allez
donc participer à ce raid dans l'équipe
des 3b ça veut dire baroudeuse blonde et
bleu et vous allez courir pour une
association c'est l'association orgue et
aux polices alors pour juste la présente
et commençons par la présenter elle
accompagne les familles de policiers
endeuillées c'est ça cette association
sur l'autre est exactement en fait c'est
une association qui se prend en charge
les orphelins de la police nationale
donc plusieurs formes de quelle manière
elle prend en charge les enfants donc ce
que ce soit un soutien moral du coup en
général les enfants perdent 1 par an ou
deux donc que ce soit un soutien moral
financier également il les accompagne
jusqu'à leur entrée dans la vie active
donc ce soit par des aides ou même pour
en accueillant les enfants faites dans
des dans des centres de vacances
justement pour leur permettre de
profiter un peu de leur jeunesse et de
passer outre les moments difficiles de
leur vie mais vous le disiez avant le
début de cet entretien si une
association que vous connaissez depuis
l'école de police que vous connaissez
depuis plusieurs années pourquoi choisir
de la soutenir qu est ce qui vous touche
finalement dans cette association c'est
un hommage que vous souhaitez rendre à
des collègues disparus
un hommage aux nombreux collègues
malheureusement qu'on perd chaque année
que ce soit sur le terrain ou par
suicide donc pour nous ça a été vraiment
l'évidence c'était sata sociales sont là
et pas une autre
alors ce raid vous allez donc le faire
en décembre ses programmes en descente
du 13 au 20 décembre
du coup pourquoi le faire sous forme de
raid pourquoi ce soutien c'est vous avez
voulu le faire sous cette forme là alors
du coup on a voulu faire sous forme de
raid parce qu'on est toutes les deux
sportives de base et du coup on voulait
vraiment mettre l'accent à conjuguer les
deux les enfants et en même temps faire
le sport et du coup on sait
saignée sur les différents raids
multisports et on s'est rendu compte que
le raid de la saharienne défendez les
droits des femmes nous qu'on a dit ban
allons
aider les enfants allons enfin soutient
aussi aux femmes
et du coup on s'est lancé dans ce raid
donc ce que celui ci serait des 100 %
féminin the lady du 13 au 20 décembre
c'est la cinquième édition au costa rica
donc il ya un angle solidaire on l'a
compris à un raid sportif ça ça consiste
en quoi
le raid de la saharienne donc serre est
donc c'est déroulera sur sept jours on a
différentes épreuves notamment du vtt du
trail de la course à pied on aura
quelques épreuves un peu plus originales
comme du lancer de hache par exemple on
a également du canoë kayak voile à
diverses épreuves tout au long de la
semaine et voilà je vous montrera les
épreuves sur les matinées les après midi
on sera auprès de la population locale
pour voir alors leur culture leurs
coutumes faire justement un lien lien
population les liens entre le sport et
la solidarité vous allez parcourir du
coup tout le costa rica ça se déroule à
travers tout le pays c'est qd on aura
une base en fait on va être logée dans
un bivouac sous des tentes
et puis on partira visiter tout le costa
rica voilà toute la semaine et je
précise sur à 70 équipes engagées à
chaque fois avec deux femmes qui
composeront chacune des équipes
commencent à se prépare physiquement
alors vous le disiez vous êtes sportif
donc j'imagine l'entretien c'est tout au
long de l'année mais pour préparer plus
particulièrement ce raid comment ça se
passe on a la chance d'avoir une base
d'entraînement sur dreux donc pas très
loin d'ici où on peut faire du canoë du
vtt donc on a fait notre première en
canoë il ya pas longtemps
c'est assez fun mais voilà on s'entraîne
souvent la barre et une première
encourageante où il ya encore du travail
non toi une première c'était pas mal
donc un ongle forcément sportif alors
pour l'angle solidarité aussi pour
pouvoir partir sur place il ya forcément
un budget de combien avez vous besoin
pour pouvoir mener à bien justement ce
projet pour pouvoir mener à bien le
projet on doit payer donc des frais
d'inscription qui s'élèvent à 7200 euros
pour notre équipe
en plus de ça on a des frais de
transport donc pour pouvoir se déplacer
au costa rica donc on
ouvert une enveloppe de 9000 9500 euros
pour être large pour ce qui aussi
matériel si on n'arrive pas à avoir des
sponsors qui fournissent du matériel
justement donc on a mis 9500 euros pour
pouvoir large et tout ce qu'il y aura au
delà de ce qu'on a besoin sera
directement reversé à l'association
orphéopolis alors vous avez donc mis en
place une cagnotte
je crois qu'aujourd'hui il ya une
centaine d'euros qu'ont déjà été
récoltés est-ce que 200 presque 200
voilà comment on peut vous et vous le
disiez on le disait via cette cagnotte
il ya aussi d'une recherche de sponsors
exactement parce qu'il faut savoir que
c'est un raid qui va être très médiatisé
donc les sponsors c'est tout à leur
avantage
alors on pourra alors faire un maximum
de publicité sur les réseaux sociaux on
va passer à la télé etc
donc voilà on cherche on cherche
activement des sponsors donc le message
à passer aujourd'hui aux téléspectateurs
c'est aider nous pour une bonne cause
très bien merci à vous bon courage dans
ce projet charlotte et marine je
rappelle que vous êtes policières l'une
de vous intervient dans les yvelines et
vous allez participer donc au rallye de
la saharienne en faveur de l'association
orgue et aux polices le rallye de la
saharienne cinquième édition
au programme du 13 au 20 décembre au
costa rica
[Musique]
mais un retour en direct avec vous mais
la nique aux quais bon soir avec on va
découvrir ce soir la commanderie
autrement le site saint quentinois va se
retrouver ce week end au centre d'un
événement particulier c'est un coup de
coeur
cette semaine qui connaît des
turbulences des turbulences mais elles
sont heureuses ces turbulences c'est en
fait le nom de la création tout droit
sorti de l'imagination d'une chorégraphe
ça va peut-être rappeler quelque chose à
nos téléspectateurs
ah oui oui nous aviez parlé d'un sujet
en mai de ce sujet en mai dernier
à l'époque c'est la chorégraphe tatiana
julien et la commanderie qui recherchait
des intéressés
une quinzaine d'entre eux a répondu
présent ils viennent d'un peu partout de
l'agglomération de 50 en une et même de
paris depuis se sont retrouvés en juin
pour créer tout cela on voit les
journées de travail à l'image il fallait
appréhender le travail de tatiana julien
mais aussi comprendre comment la
commanderie peut devenir un lieu
chorégraphique c'est de créer un projet
très immersif très plein de liberté et
de joie est quelque chose d'assez festif
avec le public où il ya une première
déambulation le public circule librement
dans tout le bâtiment et visitent le
bâtiment mais par la danse les
spectateurs vont des bons donc être
accompagnés de danseurs professionnels
et amateurs mais pas seulement mais pour
cette découverte ou la redécouverte de
la commande et seront équipés d'un
casque audio ils pourront ainsi écouter
des flux musique musicaux différents
mais aussi des réflexions sur l'art et
la danse alors tatana tatiana julien
avait déjà créé une turbulence au
château de vincennes je propose
maintenant d'écouter fanny debré les
chargés du développement artistique du
site saint quentinois et elle nous
explique ce qui les a attiré dans ce
projet on a été complètement emporté
voilà emballé par cette proposition
puisque on n'est pas dans une
représentation classique avec le public
d'un côté
le spectacle de l'autre la la danse elle
est partout alentour
le spectateur est niveau du sensation et
en plus à la commanderie c'est un lieu
fait pour des propositions inédites
original singulière alors la commanderie
et s'anime le 6 juillet prochain début
des turbulences à 21h et la soirée après
la déambulation c'est un concert dansé
au son électro d'accès drigo merci mais
l'année pour cette chronique comme
d'habitude vous serez à la présentation
du 7-8 culture c'est dans un instant sur
tv 78 enfin c'était le dernier grand
événement avant lité dans la commune
coignières organisé sa fête samedi
dernier sous une chaleur caniculaire des
genoux et des moyens de rafraîchissement
ont été déployés plusieurs animations
ont rythmé l'après midi sur le parking
de l'espace alphonse daudet un manège
trampoline et jeux gonflables pour les
enfants la journée s'est terminée par un
repas champêtre sous une ambiance
musicale avant un feu d'artifice c'est
est au stade du moulin à vent
plus de mille personnes ont pris part
aux festivités yves hub stand berger
pour les interviews on termine par la
fête de la ville a fait de coignières
qui est une tradition ici depuis depuis
des lustres cette fête et et je dirai
comment dire organiser évidemment partie
par la mairie mais surtout grâce au
comité des fêtes très très bien très
surpris je vais à l'arrivée soit n'y a
pas très longtemps donc bas pour les
enfants c'est très très bien
c'était une très belle journée bien pour
les enfants un peu chaud mais bon je
vois qu'à la ville de coignières a fait
ce qu'il fallait pour les enfants
supporter la chaleur avec les jeux d'eau
et tout donc c'est très bien
voilà c'est la fin du set 8 journal
replay sur notre site internet et notre
application mobile et rendez vous dès
demain à 18 heures pour une nouvelle
édition d'information locale en direct
belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]